the russia investigation is one step
closer to the president this morning
Special Counsel Robert Muller sent a
subpoena to the Trump Organization
demanding documents including some about
Russia
Paula Reid is at the White House with
the next step in the Russia probe while
a good morning good morning this is the
first time that we're hearing that
Special Counsel Robert Muller is seeking
documents related to the president's
personal business but a former Justice
Department official tells me it's not
really surprising that he's using what
is essentially a basic prosecutorial
tool since we know that he is interested
in that meeting at Trump Tower and we
also know from sources that he's been
asking witnesses about the Trump
Organization and any business dealings
with Russia but keep in mind the
president has said that any
investigation into his family's personal
or corporate finances would cross a a
red line the Trump Organization says it
is cooperating with the request which
was reportedly delivered in recent weeks
but this is yet another sign that this
investigation continues to expand
despite White House claims that it's
wrapping up now the scope of this
subpoena is not yet clear but what is
quite clear is that this investigation
is not wrapping up anytime soon
Norah alright Paula thank you so much